merci pierre avec ma voix tonitruante je
vais poussé un grand cri de colère je
vais je viens de terminer le schéma
d'aménagement du territoire de
l'arrondissement de ville et
l'agglomération urbaine la plus rurale
de france un hectare sur deux est en
zone agricole protégée
j'ai fait le diagnostic par rapport il
ya dix ans les territoires ruraux sont
en décrochage complet et on voit bien la
nécessité d' illustrait un ce que les
animateurs de cette table ronde vous ont
dit depuis bientôt une heure et qui a
été une formule de notre président
nicolas sarkozy qui va tout toujours à
l'essentiel
si on veut marquer les esprits et avoir
un vrai plan pour la ruralité
il faut qu'on arrive à mettre un euro en
territoire rural quand on met un euro en
territoire urbain si on n'est pas à
cette hauteur là on n'arrivera pas à
marquer les esprits parce qu'on
déclinera des tas de choses sur le
domaine de la santé sur le domaine de
l'apprentissage de l'artisanat du
commerce de la médecine tout ce qu'on
vient d'évoquer et il faut qu'on est
donc un changement de gouvernance du
dispositif
alors qu'est ce qu'un ancien ministre de
la ville comme moi bien faire sur cette
question de la ruralité même si ma
circonscription est à 50% rural c'est
justement vous expliquez que pendant des
années on a fait dans les banlieues des
politiques de la ville qui était apte
des tas de dispositifs dont certains
prisonniers mans était utile mais que
tout ça ne marchait jamais parce que
tout ça était saupoudrait tout ça était
dispersée et que ce saupoudrage et ce
gaspillage dans certaines régions voire
dans des régions socialistes copinage
aboutissait à rendre inefficace et
dispositif à partir de la loi borloo du
1er août 2003 on a fait ce qu'on a
appelé un dispositif de rénovation
urbaine avec des contrats de rénovation
urbaine qui sont qui ont été pris sur un
millier de quartiers en difficulté ce
qui correspond très bien ce que annie
genevard disais tout à l'heure sur la
nécessité de travailler en gros sur un
millier de bassin de vie c'est bien le
bassin de vie qu'est la bonne échelle de
territoire et qu'est ce qu'on a fait mon
affaire chimed avec un levier
donnez moi un levier je soulèverai le
monde
c'est à dire qu'au lieu que l'état une
politique dans un coin que la région une
politique dans un coin que les
départements pour leur voler ruralité
une politique dans un troisième quoi que
les communautés de communes face à la
hauteur de leurs moyens de plus en plus
faible que les bourgs centres dont on a
parlé aussi mettre de l'argent quelque
part on a concentré l'argent sur des
objectifs prioritaires sur des
territoires prioritaires que sont les
bassins de vie et on les a concentraient
en se mettant d'accord pour que dans une
période limitée en temps en gros cinq
ans on puisse avoir une sorte d'effet
laser de l'azéri zélés moyens avec un
contrat d'objectifs qui se signent et
qui donne une cohérence à l'ensemble du
dispositif et qui fait que sur le
territoire considéré sur le territoire
considéré on sait ce qui va se faire
et des fois les actions en matière de
médecine et création d'une maison de
santé ont un impact sur d'autres choses
sur le territoire joies d'une juste
donner un exemple pour aller cours dans
nos territoires ruraux il ya de plus en
plus de personnes âgées en particulier
qui sont ce qu'on appelle des
propriétaires occupants de leur logement
qui n'ont plus les moyens de les
entretenir parce qu'ils ont plus de
ressources
vous prenez une veuve qui a 11 100 euros
de ressources par mois elle ne sait pas
faire l'isolation thermique de son
logement
et pourtant si elle faisait l'isolation
thermique de son logement ça représente
à peu près vingt mille euros ont lu
économiserait en dépenses de chauffage à
peu près 200 euros par mois ça à peu
près 25 % de la dépense de chauffage et
si on mettait tout l'argent ensemble l'
agence nationale pour l'amélioration de
l'habitat gelé présidé à quelques années
elle met de l'argent mais c'est un
circuit totalement technocratique est
totalement compliqué les régions de
temps en temps mettre de l'argent mais
tout ça est dispersé si on mettait tous
ensemble les moyens et qu'on mettait
quelque part un dispositif qui porte le
sujet on arrive en 3 ans à amortir les
20000 euros d'isolation thermique de
l'habitation et on donne donc 200 euros
de pouvoir d'achat en plus à ces
personnes qui vont pouvoir consommer
dans des communes des petits commerces
et éviter la fermeture de petits
commerces et on donne du boulot à des
artisans et on peut faire
l'apprentissage donc on boucle la boucle
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire il
faut une sorte de plan marshall de la
ruralité si on veut être crédible et il
faut donc qu'on essaie de mettre les
mêmes moyens à la même temps
cité qu'on a su mettre sur les banlieues
mois chez moi récemment un agriculteur
m'a dit on est en train de crever vous
avez mis plein d'argent sur les
banlieues et nous nous sommes des
productif et nous sommes propriétaires
de notaire et on représentent aussi
l'avenir de la france mettez nous une
équité de traitement avec les banlieues
c'est bien ce qu'on vient vous dire ce
matin
merci marc philippe